la viè la campagne suppose d'accepter
quelques nuisances
rien ne serait plus illusoire que de
céder une vision bucolique ou fantasmés
d'une réalité paisible à fun et inodore
nos territoires ruraux ne sont pas
seulement des paysages ce sont aussi des
chants des auteurs des activités des
pratiques qui font partie de notre
patrimoine
j'ai dit rouler les eaux gijon ils sont
pas toujours habitué
le phénomène ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
on se souvient du sous préfet aux champs
dépeint par alphonse daudet dans les
lettres de mon moulin qui se laisse
perturbé dans son travail par le chant
des cigales et l'odeur des violettes ses
sonorités et ses senteurs bien agréable
sont parfois dénoncés comme des
nuisances les vocalises d'un côté un peu
trop puissant le traitement de cloche un
peu trop fréquents tout devient prétexte
à des actions en justice
soyons cependant nuancé ces conflits ne
sont pas aussi fréquent qu'on pourrait
le croire la presse en données comparées
culié souvent le cas soumis au juge dès
pas aussi caricatural qui est le laisse
penser la manière dont il est présenté
au public
je n'oppose pas les méchants néoruraux
gentil rue gros il n'y a pas d'un côté
les procéduriers est sensible aux
charmes de la campagne et de l'autre les
victimes de recours abusifs intempestif
pour autant ces conflits de voisinage
existent et se développent
vous avez d'ailleurs est-il monsieur le
rapporteur que les élus locaux que vous
avez auditionné nous ont fait part de
leur sentiment d'un accroissement des
sollicitations et des interpellations
sur ces sujets et quand on leur
demandait parfois de jouer un rôle de
médiateur qui est loin d'être évident
j'en profite pour souligner la qualité
de votre rapport et l'important travail
de recherche jurisprudentielle que vous
avez fourni pour nourrir vos travaux
vous soulignez à juste titre que la
reconnaissance des sons et des odeurs
des territoires ruraux doit permettre de
désamorcer en amont les contentieux de
voisinage
tel est l'objet de cette proposition de
loi qui est pour moi une bonne
proposition de loi de défense de la
ruralité
je suis donc particulièrement heureux
aujourd'hui
en ma qualité de secrétaire d'état la
ruralité de représenter le gouvernement
et de donner un avis favorable à
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
je me félicite d'ailleurs que la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication est adopté sans
modification et à l'unanimité cette
proposition de loi
compte tenu du temps qui nous est
désormais à partie je ne me livrerai pas
à l'exégèse de l'analyse du texte vous
pouvoir des biens des aimants
je me contentais de vous dire que je
veux remercier et à la fois vous
remercier et remercier le sénat et
saluer votre groupe et cette initiative
parlementaire dont l'auteur cabrel à
l'huissier connais bien les questions à
l'assemblée nationale
je ne doute pas de l'adoption de ce
texte c'est un signal important qui sera
envoyée aux membres rural il sera
apprécié à sa juste mesure
je vous remercie et vous fait dans des
minutes supplémentaires que j'aurais pu
utiliser à cette tribune
la parole est à monsieur pierre antoine
lévy rapporteur de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la campagne c'est cette musique cette
agitation de branches de feuilles et de
cris qui centre et cherche it etc tueur
quand on ferme les yeux
ces mots des marines des bureaux des
écrivains et beaucoup de justesse les
territoires ruraux
peut-on interdire un coq de chanter les
cigales de ce tribut l'est ou encore à
des grenouilles coassent et faut-il
mettre en sourdine les cloches des
églises les clarines des troupeaux ou la
mécanique détracteurs doit-on mettre fin
aux odeurs de purin de fumier ou de
crottin de cheval
cet été le coq maurice poursuivie au
tribunal a même acquis une notoriété
nationale dépassant largement les
frontières de sa basse-cour et de l'île
d'oléron
son sort est ainsi beaucoup plus
enviable que celui de son congénère
marcel tué par un voisin excédé par les
chants du gallinacé paix à son âme
derrière si l'afer pittoresque
clochemerlesque elles se trouvent des
problèmes de fond comme l'a souligné
notre collègue olivier paccaud lors de
l'examen du texte en commission
les élus locaux sont de plus en plus
sollicitée est appelé à intervenir en
tant que médiateur sur de tels conflits
de voisinage je tiens ici à leur rendre
hommage
notre collègue pierre marie pierre
monnier l'a très justement dit en
commission les conflits de voisinage qui
parviennent jusqu'aux tribunaux
constitue la partie émergée d'un iceberg
un bon nombre d'entre eux sont réglés
bien en amont le plus souvent grâce à la
médiation active des mères ceci comme
sur de nombreux autres sujets ne
comptent pas leurs heures pour trouver
des solutions
pacifier la situation en un mot faire
vibrer territoire les animés et
préserver le lien social
commençons nous arriver à une situation
où les élus locaux doivent justifier la
normalité des sonneries des cloches y
compris la nuit d'odeurs inhérentes aux
territoires ruraux ou du
généré par les activités agricoles des
évidences ont été oubliés j'en citerai
deux d'une part on ne vit pas la ville
comme à la campagne
les territoires ruraux ne sont pas des
territoires silencieux et inodore le
silence n'appartient pas plus à la
campagne qu'à la bile d'autre part les
jeunes dénoncés ne sont bien souvent que
la traduction d'un territoire qui vit à
des activités économiques qui lui sont
propres
la commission de la culture n'a que
rarement l'occasion d'afficher son
soutien au monde agricole
permettez moi de saisir l'occasion
offerte par ce texte concernant des
musiques pas toujours harmonieuses j'en
conviens et de nouveaux aspects du
patrimoine pour le faire enfin même la
crise de la cohydro en effet certains
direct sur la perception des sons et les
odeurs inhérents aux territoires ruraux
le confinement à contrer la population à
demeurer au sein de leur domicile
pendant de longues semaines dans
certains territoires
on a constaté une utilisation accrue des
résidences secondaires ces situations
ont parfois entraîné par sandrine et
l'exacerbation des conflits préexistants
au final ce texte arrive à un moment
propice la période particulière que nous
vivons et le développement du
télétravail
tant que la ruralité est regardée avec
un intérêt renouvelé je pense notamment
à certains habitants des territoires
urbains notamment des métropoles dans ce
contentieux contexte il me semble
important de rappeler ce fait on ne peut
pas en arrivant dans un lieu tel qui
soit se retourner immédiatement comme un
tre bruit ou une odeur inconnu il faut
accepter une période d'acclimatation qui
peut être plus ou moins longue
je salue l'initiative notre collègue
député la lozère pierre morel à
l'huissier d'avoir sollicité le
président de l'assemblée nationale pour
qu'il saisisse le conseil d'état il en
ressort un texte équilibré et
juridiquement solide pour la commission
de la culture ce texte permet
d'atteindre deux objectifs fondamentaux
il apporte une reconnaissance juridique
est donc un début de protection pour les
émissions loeffel petits vaisseaux nord
des espaces naturels
mais surtout ce texte doit servir de
base un dialogue constructif entre élus
locaux et leurs administrés qu'ils
soient habitants de longue date nouveaux
arrivants ainsi qu'avec des personnes de
passage
il prévoit ainsi de confier aux services
régionaux de l'inventaire du patrimoine
n roll d'études et de qualification de
l'identité culturelle des territoires
dans toutes les composantes du
patrimoine y compris sensorielle après
examen ce nouveau rôle confié à ses
services me semble particulièrement
important
je souhaite toutefois attirer votre
attention monsieur le ministre sur un
point les moyens financiers et humains
seront nécessaires pour mener à bien
ces nouveaux travaux le gouvernement a
accepté de lever le gage lors de
l'examen du texte à l'assemblée
nationale
je l'en remercie mais j'espère que le
soutien financier de l'état seront à la
hauteur de l'ambition affichée pour
l'élaboration de ce nouvel inventaire
je conclurai cette présentation en
citant frédéric mistral
chaque année le rossignol relevé des
plumes neuf mais il garde la même
chanson les territoires ruraux sont à
l'image de ce rossignol au fil des
saisons et des années
il évolue construisent leur avenir mais
leurs caractéristiques propres demeures
pour maurice et marcel les coques pour
victoire et pétunia vaches alpine
porteuse de clarin 3 bruyante mais
surtout pour l'ensemble des élus des
territoires ruraux qui s'investissent
chaque jour pour faire vivre et défendre
la ruralité
la commission de la culture vous propose
d'adopter conforme ce texte équilibré et
porteur d' outil de dialogue
je vous remercie à l'affût de la
discussion générale la parole et à
madame monique de marco
je tiens à vous rappeler qu'il nous
reste 26 minutes
or les temps de parole qui arrivent sont
de 45 minutes 1 alors je vous
demanderais monsieur le président
messieurs le succès d'état monsieur le
rapporteur mais chaque collègue
cette proposition de loi vise à
reconnaître dans le code de
l'environnement que le son et les odeurs
caractéristiques de la vie rurale
constitue un patrimoine sensorielle
immatériel qui mérite d'être inventorié
étudié protéger elle vise aussi
indirectement à lutter contre les
recours en justice abusif mené pas les
vacanciers ou des mieux néo ruraux qui
ont réalisé de la campagne des villages
ne visions technicolor de la nature une
image photographique inodore et
silencieuse dans ces conflits de
voisinage est aussi un conflit de
territoire qui se joue avec des
frontières de plus en plus floue entre
le périurbain la compagne et lui en
gironde
je constate c'est qu'on n'est que nos
zones rurales de la métropole bordelaise
et bien d'autres sont menacées par
l'artificialisation des sols les zones
commerciales lotissement et autres
entrepôts fleurissent ici et là dans des
zones agricoles des classes et
l'étalement urbain occasion de nouveaux
troubles de voisinage
ce texte propose une reconnaissance
essentiellement symbolique des 100 et
odeurs de la campagne mais aussi un
travail pour mieux connaître le
traitement juridique des conseils de
voisinage et apprécier la spécificité
des territoires ruraux
il nous semble incongru de passer par la
voie législative pour traiter ce sujet
d'autant que la portée juridique cette
proposition de loi est restreinte
je terminerai par une réflexion plus
large pour éviter de rester dans une
vision idéalisée de la campagne pourquoi
parce que les activités agricoles
rurales sont en constante évolution ce
patrimoine sensorielle que nous
souhaitons préserver aujourd'hui a été
mise à mal par des décennies
d'intensification des pratiques
agricoles
depuis les déserts de la monoculture aux
ravages des algues vertes sur le
littoral de la disparition des des
élevages intensifs aux projets de fermes
usines qui dont les émanations de
certaines banques à préserver
sans oublier les épandages de pesticides
qui n'ont presque pas d'odeur mais
réduisent des millions d'oiseaux et
d'insectes au silence néanmoins le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires est favorable à ce texte qui
constitue un effort louable est une
première étape pour favoriser le vivre
ensemble pendant manège avait dans le
groupe r des pays
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues c'était le clocher
de saint-hilaire qui donnait à toutes
les occupations à toutes les heures à
tous les points de vue de la ville leurs
figures leur couronnement leur
consécration cette phrase de marcel
proust est emblématique de l'atmosphère
qui règne dans la recherche de temps
perdu
chef-d'oeuvre de notre littérature qui
regorge de clocher de bruit et des plus
faibles de la campagne notamment celle
des célèbres aubépines l'oeuvre de
proust nous montre combien l'identité de
nos territoires se construit bien
souvent par les sons et les odeurs
qu'ils produisent ces sons et ses odeurs
constitue en quelque sorte le premier
contact le contact le plus immédiat que
nous offre le monde rural
de ce fait l'attachement que l'on porte
à nos territoires est immanquablement
liés à ces bruits et odeurs qu'ils
produisent cependant que vous le savez
ces sons et ses odeurs sont aussi le
produit de l'activité économique des
territoires
l'image d'epinal de la campagne et je le
regrette conduit parfois à l'opposé
catégoriquement à la ville l'imaginé
silencieuse est endormi alors que le
monde rural est évidemment dynamique et
qui comporte faut-il le rappeler une
part importante d'activités productives
agricoles artisanales et industrielles
en ce sens ces sons et ses odeurs qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui en sont une
manifestation parmi tant d'autres je
retiens par ailleurs de cette
proposition de loi qu'elle ambitionne de
consolider le vivre ensemble la cohésion
l'unité de nos territoires qui parfois
est mise à mal par ces litiges entre néo
ruraux et ruraux ces derniers placent
d'ailleurs les élus locaux dans une
situation délicate puisqu'ils sont
fréquemment sollicité par ce type de
conflits de voisinage en somme c'est
question du vivre ensemble est d'autant
plus urgente qu elle advient au moment
où il est partout fragiliser alors pour
toutes ces raisons on ne peut que saluer
cette initiative de consacrer au rang de
composantes du patrimoine commun de la
nation
les sons et les odeurs notre notre
environnement et de les inventorier
notre groupe votera pour cette
proposition de loi
l'apparent l'état monsieur christian
bilhac pour le groupe rdse
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues attendu que la poule est
un animal à dourdain est stupide au
point que nul n'était encore parvenue à
le dresser pas même un cirque chinois
que son voisinage comporte beaucoup de
silences eu quelques tendre bushman des
caquètements qui vont du joyeux pour la
punt de neufs offerts en dégustation
d'un ver de terre en passant par la
folle et vue du renard que ce pénible
voisinage n'a jamais au mode et que ce
qui pour d'autres motifs touriste du
courroux à l'égard des propriétaires de
ces gallinacés que la cour ne jugera pas
que le bateau importune le marin la
farine le boulanger le violon le chef
d'orchestre est là pour un habitant du
lieu dit la rochette village de saleh
dans le département du puy de dôme
par ces motifs statuant publiquement
contradictoirement infirme le jugement
des boutefeux rouge effraction et le
condamne au départ ce sont les termes
exacts de l'arrêt de la cour de riyom en
date du 5 septembre 1995 portant sur un
conflit de voisinage sujet d'un
poulailler
par cet arrêt le juge reconnaît qu'il
convient d'accepter un habitant à la
campagne les avantages et inconvénients
que cela comporte
depuis nous avons connu à faire du
désormais célèbre feu le corps maurice
trépassé en mai dernier sur l'île
d'oléron
mais également les canards landais des
vaches ont peu partout sur leur histoire
à cause de leurs cloches ou de l'odeur
les tables sans oublier lane
les tracteurs les cigales les
grenouilles et j'en oublie certainement
en ma qualité de maire j'ai moi même été
convoqué au tribunal suite à la plainte
de nouvelles habitants incommodés par la
sonnerie des cloches de l'horloge de
perret chaque maire rural de notre pays
pourrait enrichir notre débat avec une
ou plusieurs anecdotes
aujourd'hui le monde rural n'est plus
exclusivement agricole avec ses coutumes
les saurine de vie partagée par touches
le prolongement de la vie lors de la
ville a profondément modifié la
structure sociétale de la ruralité
chez nous on habite à leçons quand même
une véritable chance pour le monde rural
ils permettent en effet de maintenir la
vie dans les campagnes de conserver
l'école
le bistrot épicerie mais en même temps
des difficultés sont apparues et se
traduisent par une judiciarisation
croissante cela provienne de la
méconnaissance de la réalité souvent
perçu de manière idéalisée
karl est de plus en plus associé un lieu
de vacances et non pas seulement un lieu
de vie et de résidence un autre aspect
n'est pas d'aborder là le texte j'ai eu
je l'aborderai rapidement il concerne
les conscrits et la propriété foncière à
l'utilisation des sols de plus en plus
on entend que la nature et à tout le
monde et doit être partagée
si cela est le cas dans les pays
nordiques que ce n'est pas le cas en
france où la majorité de nos campagnes
appartient à une multitude de
propriétaires privés
ses propriétaires terriens ont de tout
temps accepté que les promeneurs les
randonneurs et les cueilleurs de
champignons parcours leurs terres mais
je comprenais pas aujourd'hui de voir
remis encore de le revoir le chasse ou
de propriété il convient de rappeler que
le droit de propriété est un droit
imprescriptible figurant à l'article 17
de la déclaration universelle des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen notre société a
évolué et doit évoluer mais dans ce
domaine comme tant d'autres le dialogue
on laisse trop souvent la place aux
invectives aux actions en justice est
partout à la ville comme à la campagne
la tolérance et la compréhension
mutuelle disparaissent mais cette
proposition de loi contribuera à pallier
ces difficultés en clarifiant les
responsabilités de chacun et en
reconnaissant le patrimoine sensorielle
dans nos territoires dans toutes ses
facettes
le groupe rdse votera donc en faveur de
fautes adoption je remercie la parole et
à madame céline brulin pour le groupe
crc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues ce texte vise à
répondre à une interpellation récurrente
des élus locaux la gêne ressort ce
ressenti par certains de nos concitoyens
à l'égard ici d'un coq un peu trop
enjouée la de grenouilles qui coassent à
des heures indues ou pas du reste et aux
conflits qui peuvent en découler et qui
empoisonnent parfois la vie des élus
locaux des mères en particulier qui ont
bien d'autres choses et d'autres crises
à gérer en ce moment on en a tous bien
conscience ici donc nous voterons
évidemment ce texte
attention cependant à l'article 1 qui
renforce les missions 1 1 bis pardon qui
renforce les missions des services
régionaux de l'inventaire général qui
peine déjà à réaliser leur mission
puisque depuis qu'elles ont été confiées
aux régions en 2005 elles n'ont pas
encore pu réaliser l'ensemble de
l'inventaire du patrimoine et leur
confier de nouvelles missions sans
nouveaux moyens peut évidemment leur
compliquer leur compliquer la tâche
nous saluons l'article inter qui va
permettre sans doute de mieux identifier
ce qui relève ou non du trouble de
voisinage afin de faire évoluer la
législation
et là encore d'apporter des réponses
concrètes aux élus locaux mais et chacun
on a conscience ici cette proposition de
loi n'est puise malheureusement pas tout
un tas de sujets sous jacent le fait que
par exemple nos concitoyens conçoivent
un peu leur habitat aujourd'hui comme un
lieu qui doit être hermétiquement isolé
de tout le reste du monde ce qui dit
quelque chose de notre société celui de
la judiciarisation qui vient essayer de
régler de plus en plus les conflits
alors que ça n'est pas toujours comme ça
qu'on les appelle au contraire
et puis peut-être celui d'une conception
ça a été dit idéalisé voire erronée de
la nature ou de la vie en milieu rural
la campagne un peu conçues comme un
milieu sous cloche dépourvu de toute
activité humaine ce qui n'est évidemment
pas le cas
sans doute nous faut-il réfléchir aussi
au fait que vivre dans les grandes
agglomérations dans le coeur des
métropoles est aujourd'hui inabordable
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens compte
tenu de l'évolution du prix du foncier
et qu'ils se retrouvent dans des zones
périurbaines ou rurales sans l'avoir
nécessairement choisi et que ce qui
devait ressembler à une forme
d'ascenseur social se traduit parfois
par le sentiment de déclassement
d'abandon avec leurs sentiments qui va
avec
ces sujets là ne sont donc pas épuisé je
crois que ça appelle du travail de notre
part la défense des services publics
surtout nos territoires puisque nous
considérons qu aucun d'eux ne doivent
être abandonnées et je voudrais terminer
en disant que vivre à la campagne vivant
ruralité c'est aussi beaucoup source
d'épanouissement pour chacun certains
l'ont découvert à la faveur notamment du
confinement et qu'il ne faut pas sans
doute donner plus d'importance à des
phénomènes qui dont la médiatisation et
parfois inversement proportionnelle à la
réalité de la situation je vous remercie
madame e mounier
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la cigale
s'endort comme meurent un poète
las d'avoir vécu fier d'avoir chanté
écrivait maurice faure sénateur de la
drôme de 1902 en 1919
ancien ministre radical socialiste n'est
mort dans son département dans un petit
village
il a vécu dans un petit village de
saillant et dont beaucoup ignorent
sûrement dans cet hémicycle qu'il était
aussi poète si le champ de la cigale
inspire de si beaux verres c'est qu'il
est partie intégrante de l'essence du
sud
j'éprouve pour ma part un plaisir tout
particulier à l'entendre raisonnée de
piment département de la drôme
cette beauté n'est pourtant pas
perceptible par tous en témoigne la
fameuse affaire des cigales qui a éclaté
dans le var en 2018
s'inscrivant dans la droite lignée des
complète dénoncent entre autres le chant
du coq
si tous ces conflits ne parviennent pas
toujours jusqu'au tribunal
ils rencontrent souvent une forte
résonance dans les médias locaux et
nationaux symptomatique de l'intérêt que
porte l'opinion publique à ce sujet il
nous faut prendre garde aux clivages qui
semble ainsi se dessiner opposant
habitants de longue date des territoires
ruraux et nouveaux arrivants
il traduit selon moi l'individualisation
de notre société où de plus en plus de
personnes sont réticentes à faire
l'effort de compréhension mutuelle et
d'ouverture nécessaire au vivre ensemble
je pense à ce titre à l'expression très
juste d'une vie en îlots employés par
david danielle even au cours de nos
auditions
christian hugonnet ingénieurs acoustique
lors de son audition souligné qu'en
matière de bruit les décibels ne font
pas tout il faut un certain temps pour
s'habituer à un nouvel environnement
sonore c'est un temps que certains ne
sont pas prêts à prendre d'autant qu'ils
arrivent souvent fort d'une vision
erronée de la ruralité fantasmes et
comme un havre au calme loin de
l'agitation urbaine celles et ceux qui
pratiquent au quotidien et territoires
ruraux savent pourtant qu'ils bruisse de
sang et l'odeur liés aux activités
indispensables à la vie de ces
territoires
je pense par exemple au bruit nocturne
détracteurs des viticulteurs drômois il
n'est sans nul doute non
ces serres de faire preuve de pédagogie
pour déconstruire les idées reçues
autour de la ruralité et des pratiques
agricoles qu'elle soit négative ou en
image d'epinal et de faire prendre
conscience des réalités de ces
territoires et de leurs habitants c'est
un travail de longue haleine mené
principalement aujourd'hui par nos élus
ruraux en première ligne de ces conflits
de voisinage leur médiation suffit
souvent à désamorcer ces conflits avant
qu'il ne donne lieu à des poursuites
nous nous devons de les assurer de notre
soutien plein et entier
cette proposition de loi est la portée
plus symbolique de pratique ne doit pas
être perçu comme un renfermement sur eux
mêmes des territoires ruraux dont nous
connaissons toutes et tous la capacité
d'innovation et d'adaptation en posant
les premiers jalons d'une discussion
collective sur ce sujet essentiel
elle constitue au contraire une
célébration de ce qui fait leur saveur
leur identité est un mois un signal fort
de notre part aux élus ruraux pour
toutes les raisons évoquées le groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
votera ce test juste et fera plier pour
3 minutes
monsieur le président sur nice mes chers
collègues des territoires et des
terroirs
imaginez une matinée d'été un coq qui
chante pour accueillir le soleil le
moteur d'un tracteur gagnant les champs
et le clocher d'une église qui sont à
l'angélus à cette heure vous ne rêvez
pas vous êtes bien en france mais contre
toute attente et face à l'agression bobo
east nous devons légiférer devant ces
évidences pour écrire dans la loi qu'il
est normal qu'un coq chante de la
campagne qu'une vache porte une cloche à
la montagne que les grenouilles coassent
au bord de leur étant retombée pu
imaginer dans la provence des années 50
le père de marcel pagnol néorural
professeurs et fonctionnaires porté
plainte à coin du chant des cigales de
la garrigue et du son des cloches des
églises
c'est pourtant aujourd'hui la triste
réalité les mêmes qui supporte les
bruits le bruit infernal des du
périphérique et des autoroutes et qui
s'abrutissent dans les centres
commerciaux exige le silence absolu dans
les campagnes les attaque en justice se
sont multipliés ces dernières années à
l'encontre de tout ce qui fait l'âme de
temps et de nos territoires ruraux les
touristes vacanciers et néo ruraux ont
multiplié les plaintes à l'encontre de
bruits et d'odeurs inhérents la vie
rurale est présent depuis toujours des
bruits et des odeurs mes chers collègues
des chants et des saveurs
il s'agit donc de protéger notre culture
nos racines au sens premier de terroir
et au sens plus large de civilisation
cette nouvelle loi prévoit de protéger
le patrimoine sensorielle des campagnes
françaises
il faut évidemment reconnaître qu'il
existe un héritage rural qui au delà de
simples sont et senteurs incarne un mode
de vie ancestral ceux qui attaquaient
les villes doivent axe qui quittent
pardon les villes doivent je dis bien
doivent accepter que la campagne ne soit
pas une nature aseptisé normalisée
là aussi il s'agit d'assimilation
l'assimilation finalement c'est le
respect de la terre qui accueille et
l'adoption inconditionnel de ses
traditions mais l'objectif de cette loi
est aussi de défendre nos paysans ceux
qui nourrissent chaque jour malgré la
rudesse de leur métier doivent être au
centre de nos préoccupations
cette problématique est beaucoup plus
large que cette simple proposition de
loi la réalité démographique nous le
montre dans toutes nos régions le choc
social entre 2
nos cultures différentes bascule dans
l'agressivité les paysans et autres
ruraux vont se retrouver de plus en plus
menacé par les zones péri urbaines qui
repousse les limites des villes en 40
ans plus de 2 millions d'hectares de
surfaces agricoles ont disparu au profit
de l'artificialisation des sols en
parallèle entre un geek agriculture
continue de sombrer dans une grave crise
parmi les exploitants agricoles la
mortalité par suicide pardon est la plus
élevée de toutes les catégories sociales
nous devons veiller à défendre la
paysannerie française labourage et
pâturage sont les deux mamelles de la
france disait sully la campagne la
culture élevage font partie de notre adn
aujourd'hui les mais les personnes qui
n'acceptent pas d'entendre une
moissonneuse travailler la nuit sont la
tristesse d'autre de notre pays et les
fossoyeurs de notre identité
chers collègues il appartient d'incarner
la défense de notre patrimoine matériel
et immatériel rural de nos territoires
dans nos terroirs du mode de vie des
paysans de nos cultures nos coutumes car
ils sont la cellule souche de notre pays
pas de pays sans paysans dois je le
rappeler
face à l'offensive de bobos qui n'ont à
ise cela devient manifestement urgent
monsieur bako pour les républicains
monsieur le président chers collègues il
est des lois subtilement utile ou
utilement subtil c'est le cas de ce
texte ni anecdotique ni folklorique mais
au contraire symbolique symbolique des
chances que nous souhaitons donner à ce
fameux vivre ensemble symbolique de
l'attention que nous souhaitons porter à
la ruralité
cette réalité souvent oubliée méprisé
que certains voudraient voir transformée
en musée c'est 15 millions de français
et vintimille commune qui n'incarne pas
que le passé et veulent avoir un avenir
ces campagnes résonnent des moteurs de
tracteurs mais aussi certains gros
immémoriaux et souvent animaux ou
quelques effluves peu raffiné viennent
parfois perturber des odorat délicat
c'est ainsi que régulièrement des
néoruraux ou parfois des touristes mal
embouché viennent utiliser de leurs
droits devant les tribunaux ou faire le
siège d'une mairie pour dénoncer des
troubles anormaux de voisinage entre
quelques grenouilles d'indiscipliné des
coques ténors des cloches trop matinal
et des cigales tractant trop fort mais
exemple de plaintes et des marchés us qu
mais bien réels ne sont pas si rares
cependant plus qu'une loi c'est une
vision de notre société une philosophie
de notre vivre ensemble qui sont en jeu
que veux tu ont donc une ruralité de
cartes postales sans saveur ni odeur une
ruralité police et le poc sait se tenir
ou lan a perdu sa voix
mais cloches sont de marbre et muette
le claquement des sabots sur le bitume
s'est évanoui ou la transhumance ne
carillonne pas éminente plus les routes
des équipes de trois ans que le temps
donc une société où l'individualisme
exacerbé les ola sionisme aveugle
triomphe où l'on ne vit plus ensemble
mais côte-à-côte hermétiquement séparés
les relations sociales se judiciarise de
plus en plus où l'on veut faire tabula
rasa de nos héritages millénaire naturel
et civilisationnel au nom d'une
modernité égoïste et intolérante
le patrimoine c'est ce que nous ont
légué transmis offert nos pères
c'est une part profonde ancestrale
authentiques de notre identité c'est
patrimoine et naturelles minérales
monumental peut-être aussi sensorielle
proust et sa madeleine
nous l'ont appris souhaite tente donc de
venir des mannequins robotisée des
racines et calfeutrés dans un
environnement aseptisé de science
fiction comme la campagne l'état de
droit ses charmes et ses méfaits
probablement est-il regrettable de
devoir passer par la loi pour protéger
notre patrimoine sensorielle mais c'est
ainsi et désormais si nous parachevant
le travail commencé par l'assemblée les
grincheux verront leur accès limité dans
les tribunaux et nos mères ils gagneront
un bouclier de sagesse et de
tranquillité ce texte
ce sera donc voté de façon conforme par
les républicains sans se boucher le nez
ni les oreilles le show claude marais
pour 4 minutes
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cette proposition de loi
destinée à protéger le patrimoine
sensorielle de nos campagnes pourrait
paraître surprenante elle s'inscrit
pourtant dans le contexte de la
judiciarisation croissante de nos
sociétés interroge l'identité de nos
territoires et notre capacité à user de
bon sens lorsqu'il s'agit de régler les
différends
si les querelles de voisinage ont
toujours existé la médiatisation de
certaines affaires a placé sur le devant
de la scène ces marqueurs patrimoniaux
que sont les bruits et les odeurs
caractéristiques du monde rural
il s'agissait initialement d'inscrire la
notion de patrimoine sensorielle au sein
du code du patrimoine
l'odeur de la proposition de loi a eu la
sagesse de soumettre son texte au
conseil d'état suite à ces
recommandations la commission des
affaires culturelles de l'assemblée
nationale a choisi de restreindre le
périmètre du texte aux seuls aspects
sonores et olfactives des marqueurs en
seront sélectionnés par une commission
départementale selon qu'ils présentent
ou non un intérêt suffisant pour rendre
désirable leur préservation
aussi chant des cigales danse des
abeilles bellemans de moutons pourrait
prochainement entrer dans le périmètre
de protection du code de l'environnement
il ne s'agit pas d'opposer agriculteurs
néo ruraux ou touristes mais de
consigner l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde rural afin de permettre le vivre
ensemble en bonne intelligence
l'intégration des nouveaux arrivants et
des vacanciers aux activités d'un
village est un facteur essentiel
d'attractivité
mais les difficultés d'adaptation à la
vie locale constitue le principal
facteur d'échec de ces installations
tout comme les difficultés d'intégration
sociale or deux millions de citadins
quittent chaque année les villes pour
s'installer à la campagne
ce nouvel exode urbain est un fait de
société appelé à s'accentuer salon
l'intérêt nos concitoyens pour les
ruralité mais quitter le brouhaha des
grandes agglomérations mais pas synonyme
de calme absolu
la campagne à son propre rythme de vie
du son des carillons des églises au
chant du coq en passant par les
épandages d'engrais
ou de fumier d'animaux les risques de
tension que nouveaux arrivants et
agriculteurs figurent parmi les
premières craintes des élus locaux
soulevées par ces installations
même si les litiges concernent avant
tout des problèmes plus structurants que
sont la dépendance à la voiture lusage
des sols ou la qualité de l'eau dans un
contexte où le recours au télétravail
s'intensifient les installations vers
les campagnes sont un levier important
de dynamisme territoriale et contribuer
au rééquilibrage de nos territoires
il est essentiel de ne pas décourager
les vocations tout en respectant
l'identité la culture du monde rural
le groupe des indépendants rejoint la
commission de la culture de ces
conclusions et soutient cette
proposition de loi
le temps écoulé était et s'est écoulé on
pourrait y poursuivre l'examen des
article 6 les deux orateurs les deux
derniers orateurs accepte de se retirer
we are et rim ses privilèges d'accord
alors je vais aux voix l'article 1er
quels sont ceux qui sont pour quels sont
ceux qui sont contre l'article 1er est
adopté je mets aux voix l'article 1er
bis tel ce même vote
l'article premier ter même beau
l'article 2 supprimés je mets au revoir
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
quels sont ceux qui sont pour quand la
proposition de loi est adopté
[Musique]